bonsoir clara bouaziz merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rtl france votre père
en izod aurait donc décédé au mois
d'avril des suites du coc vide en coin
estimez-vous que l'état est responsable
alors j'estime que l'état est
responsable parce que mon père n'a pas
été protégé d'une part il n'a même pas
été prévenus
informé de la présence de cette épidémie
qui a commencé quand même relativement
tôt il n'a pas eu de masques il n'a pas
eu de test
il n'a il n'a rien eu j'ai fait
énormément de pharmacie pour trouver de
quoi les protéger pas de masque pas de
thèse pas de gants pas de gel même pas
d'alcool à 60° rien du tout donc ils se
sont retrouvés seuls
et mes parents se sont confinés on a
supposé qu'ils avaient locaux vides et
il y avait un petit message de passer à
la télévision moi j'ai trouvé ce message
assez mortifère on le disait que comment
dire si on avait un peu de températures
un peu de fièvre
effectivement on était malade et on
proposait donc aux patients de rester
confinés chez eux de s'infecter entre
eux et ma foi et d'attendre que ça passe
au bout de quelques jours
si malheureusement ça ne passait pas il
fallait éventuellement appelé un médecin
ou appeler le samu quand on avait des
difficultés respiratoires
sauf que quand on appelle le samu et que
l'on a des difficultés respiratoires
il est quasiment trop tard comment ce
plu oui oui
pardonnez moi oui je vous laisse se
poursuivre je pensais que vous avez
depuis les terminer même la question
suivante mieux vous allez vous allez y
répondent évidemment en terminant votre
propos c'était comment justement s'est
passée sa prise en charge la prise en
charge de votre papa au niveau
hospitalier je me laisse se terminer
votre récit bien évidemment oui alors
mon récit c'était ce que je voulais je
voulais
insister sur le fait aussi qu'il avait
été qu'ils avaient été confinés très
tardivement c'est à dire que chaque jour
je me demandais quand on allait recevoir
ce message un petit peu gouvernementale
pour nous prévenir du confinement pour
que nous soyons au moins protégés en
attendant de nous organiser et en fait
il a fallu attendre le passage des
élections vous savez municipal c'est à
dire que un jour avant les élections ont
été libres on se baladait dans les rues
comme si de rien n'était alors que le
microbe le virus était là l'épidémie
était là et un jour après les élections
c'était la guerre on était entré en
confinement donc vous savez c'était une
limite très très ténu qui qui qui est
qui dépend des de ces élections est
malheureusement ces élections retardées
le confinement bon comment s'est ensuite
justement aux normes et à ma question
passer sa prise en charge
oui alors la prise en charge a été assez
difficile à oui je n'ai pas on n'a pas
pu faire de test je dois insister sur le
fait que je gérais dans les rues de
paris
j'appelais tous les labos et je les
suppliais de venir faire des tests pour
mes parents mais quand je vous dis
suppliait je pleurais dans la rue je
demandai je disais je vous supplie je
vous en supplie venez faire des tests à
ma famille ils sont tous malades il faut
les prendre en charge et les labos me
répondez nous n'avons pas d'agrément
nous n'avons pas d'agrément j'ai même
appelé les labos comment dire
vétérinaire en les suppliant également
devenir mais rien n'y a fait c'est à
dire qu'on n'avait pas l'agrément
c'était impossible sauf que sauf que
j'ai déposé une plainte à la cour de
justice de la république et en cherchant
je me suis rendu compte qu'il y avait
énormément demi
deux députés etc qui eux au mois de mars
avait réussi à se faire tester pendant
que moi j'ai ré dans les rues pendant
que je pleurais pour mes parents se
faisait testées se faisait hospitalisé
les parents n'ont pas le droit à ça
c'est à dire deux poids deux mesure de
dire que la vie de mon père au jour
d'aujourd'hui s'il avait eu le même le
même fort que cette personne mon père
serait vivant à côté de moi mais là donc
nous n'avons pas eu droit au test
contrairement à la prise en charge en
donnez moi c'est ton ministre que nous
en voulaient pas ce que vous tentez
clairement où plein contre les mines ce
qu'on a cité tout à l'heure c'est à eux
que vous en voulez ou c'est au système
qu'ils incarnent
alors j'en veux j'en veux aux ministres
bien évidemment ils font les
superviseurs du système je suis désolé
dans ce système on a des fonctionnaires
on a des personnes qui travaillent mais
nous avons monsieur edouard philippe qui
est le superviseur numéro un
madame agnès buzyn qui est le
superviseur de la santé et puis après
nous avons jérôme salomon les
fonctionnaires et cetera
il ya tout un tout un ensemble qui qui
marchent de pair donc bien évidemment
j'en veux aux ministres aujourd'hui
c'est un combat judiciaire qui commence
pour vous qu'est ce qu'on vous en
attendez le la reconnaissance du statut
de victime tout simplement en tout cas
pour votre papa
j'en attends le statut de victime mais
je veux des responsables il y à des
responsables
mon père était en excellente santé il
était dans la vie mon père c'est
quelqu'un qui allait à la piscine avant
avant le que vit tous les jours
c'est quelqu'un qui faisait ses courses
qui cuisinait qui nous faisait des
confitures qui faisait de la peinture
pour tous ces petits enfants chacun un
tableau tous les jeudis recevait le
dernier nouveau né de la famille s'en
occuper avec ma mère nous étions en
train de préparer un voyage à l'étranger
au maroc où ils voulaient nous nous nous
amener sur les traces de son enfance et
cetera donc il n'avait aucune raison
de de tomber malade et de mourir
aucune il n'a pas été protégé pas de
match rien du tout c'est quelque chose
d'inconcevable je dois dire qu agnès
buzyn a prévenu en janvier
monsieur macron elle a prévenu edouard
philippe elle a prévenu jérôme leman eux
étaient prévenus nous nous étions pas
prévenu du danger mais prévention égale
prévenir prévenir égale prévention c'est
la moindre des choses on l'a fait on a
on comment dire on a méprisé la vie des
français on a méprisé la vie des
citoyens
c'est inacceptable les masques n'était
pas nécessaire mais depuis quand les
masques ils ne sont pas nécessaires lors
d'une épidémie
je veux dire c'est une question de bon
sens une femme qui accouche si on veut
la visite et si on veut la voir et que
vous êtes enrhumé il y à une infirmière
qui n'aura pas fait polytechnique ni
sciences po qui va vous dire s'il vous
plaît mettez un masque
on l'attendait pas positif il faut bien
il faut bien appeler à l'époque
justement c'est peut-être là que le bât
blesse c'est qu'il n'y avait tout
simplement pas de demain est-ce que vous
pensez que ces ministres ont menti
sciemment justement où il ya eu de la
négligence il ya eu selon but du
mensonge tout simplement ou un scandale
d'état d'ailleurs c'est c'est un très
grand mensonge et qui puisait c'est une
irresponsabilité parce que tout
simplement on envoyait 17 tonnes de
matériel médical en chine dans ses 17
tonnes il y avait des combinaisons il y
avait des masques il y avait des gants
il y avait du gel en retour la chine
nous envoyait un million de masques pour
nous aider donc on s'est dénudée pour la
chine c'est une chose auquel nous
n'avons plus rien mais s'il vous plaît
on peut on a affaire à un pays où les
les citoyens sont sont intelligents nous
n'avons pas de masque tout simplement
tout simplement
et bien on fait appel à la force vive du
du pays et ont retroussé nos manches
on demande à toutes les femmes qui
savent coudre de faire des masques moi
j'ai une copine qui a fait une centaine
de masques on prévient on ya des
retouches heures il ya des usines de
tissus toutes les femmes qui ont des
machines à coudre peut faire des
on n'est pas bête on a on comprend les
choses d'ailleurs d'ailleurs les
français se sont mis à faire des masques
ils n'ont plus attendus attendre quoi il
n'y avait rien donc ils se sont mis à
faire des maths mais nous on aurait pu
nous le dire dès le début c'est comme
les usines on aurait pu dire
réquisitionner les usines par exemple de
plexiglas comment expliquez-vous que au
mois de mai alors là le plexiglas est
apparue de tous les côtés on a protégé
les taxis on a protégé les banques ont à
protéger les caisses on a pu me déplacer
mais on pouvait pas le faire avant on ne
pouvait pas réquisitionnés combien de
chauffeurs de taxi sont morts donnez moi
c'était le tout début de la crise
malheureusement le virus était moins
connu qu'aujourd'hui
est ce que vous estimez qu'à ce jour la
stratégie du gouvernement s'est
améliorée oui ou non notamment sur les
vaccins par exemple écouter sur les
vaccins vous trouvez que c'est très
positive où il est trouvée actif vous
les trouvez dynamique vous trouvez que
ça bouge
moi je connais une vieille dame de 88
ans on lui a proposé d'aller faire son
vaccin à lille est ce que c'est normal
elle habite paris elle a pas encore fait
c'est pas normal
mon et puis qui plus est on vous ton
vous dont on vous demande de vous
connecter sur internet
à chaque fois on vous demande de
connecter sur internet mais vous
imaginez vous des personnes de 80 de 88
ans 90 ans se connecter sur internet
c'est en dépit du bon sens c'est comme
si on envoyait du riz en afrique où il
n'y a pas d'eau quoi je veux dire les
personnes âgées on les prend en charge
réellement
merci en tout cas clara bouaziz de nous
avoir apporté votre témoignage en direct
sur rt france merci souligné quelque
chose à ce sujet deux minutes en plus
oui oui mon père a été
à l'hôpital où on a cru qu'il serait
prise en charge est en fait il n'a pas
il n'a pas été soignée il n'a pas reçu
de perfusions d'antibiotiques et il
s'avère qu'avec sa dépression
respiratoire trois jours après son
arrivée
on lui a donné une injection
d'anxiolytiques et de morphiniques donc
ce qui l'a terrassé quelques jours plus
tard il est décédé quelques jours plus
tard on ne donne pas de morphiniques on
ne donne pas donc scioli tic à quelqu'un
qui a une dépression respiratoire donc
là encore je suis dans l'obligation de
le déposer une plainte contre l'hôpital
et le médecin qui a pris cette décision
inacceptable et et infâme
merci en tout cas que l'arabe oasis
d'avoir été avec nous et merci pour
votre témoignage